Michel Platini the former head of
European football's governing body UEFA
has been taken into custody in France
it's happening amid an investigation
into alleged vote rigging for the right
to host the 2022 World Cup which Qatar
won
here's our teas Alexia Rashad ski the
main allegation the core of the
allegation is a supposed bribery which
may have taken place nine days before
the FIFA ballot was cast deciding the
2022 World Cup host country which
eventually went to Qatar shell party
knee wasn't the only person to be taken
into custody on Tuesday morning along
with him were civilians a former adviser
to Nicolas Sarkozy and also clogged
again the former head of Sarkozy's
administration there are also suspects
in this case the allegation is that
Michele poutine and a couple of persons
from Nicolas Sarkozy's administration of
held a meeting with then prime minister
of Qatar and the foreign minister of
Qatar and the investigators are
suspecting that they may have been
bribed into voting for Qatar Michel
Platini on numerous occasions back in
the day said that he would contemplate
voting for the United States for the
2022 World Cup but he eventually voted
for Qatar and he also admitted to that
every time there is a big world cup or a
major football tournament going on there
there are a lot of scandals there all of
political controversies and and
conspiracy theories flying about we saw
the same case in 20 2012 when the euros
were held in Poland in Ukraine the same
applied to Russia and the World Cup last
year there was a lot of safety concerns
but we all know that everything went
well so Qatar is no exception to that
since 2012 there has been a major
investigation allegations of bribery
allegations of political masterminding
of this World Cup even more so we've
heard an opinion from a number of
investigators that several countries
surrounding Qatar may have been plotting
a campaign to derail the World Cup in
2022 in Qatar but all the officials from
different football governing bodies
including feaf including UEFA that I've
been able to speak to over the last
couple of years they've all said in one
voice that the World Cup in Qatar will
take place and moreover just recently
the FIFA president Jani Infantino in
during a meeting in the Kremlin told me
that the meeting will other that the
World Cup will take place and moreover
the plan to have 48 teams in Qatar was
scrapped leaving it to 32 teams but he
still reassured that it will go on as
planned
you